foreign
welcome to today's session
my name is Sachin Segal and I'm here to
talk about a very important tool Google
ads and out of all the ads we can create
under Google ads today we would be
talking about a very important one
Google search ad
this is going to be very exciting this
is going to be very deep from my
experience I can say I will going to
take you through a lot of technical
aspects and lot of optimization
strategies where you can really bring
down the cost down if you're really
paying high for your clicks and
conversion so please be with me and I
would try to give you the best from my
site great so let's just start guys
Google ads is something which we have
discussed in the last class if you have
seen my last session if you have not we
will leave the link in the description
where we talked about the basics of
Google ads and we also talked about how
to create this beautiful ad account or a
tool with a free Gmail ID okay
we did talked about few more things that
how many types of ads you can create
just to give you the quick glimpse we
are on Google and when we type something
like if I want to do a data analytics
course
so I would type few things like a word
or a keyword or a query into Google
search engine and then Google as a
search engine would show me few results
the results which we see on the top we
are talking about these today you know
this is the topic or this is the kind of
an ad which we would create today in
this session this is called techstad or
this is also called Google search ad
okay so this is the first type of an ad
you see or which you can create under
the Google ads there are a few more just
like if you would go and search for any
of the e-commerce product probably by
winter
jacket
online
so then there would be results but in a
different shape and color and different
structure there is an ad which is a text
ad but on the top we are able to see
some more ads but they are not just text
they have a pricing they have a title
they have a brand name they have an
image of the product so they are called
shopping ads or product listing ads in
addition to that sometimes you know when
you go to a product a website like speed
test and you see the product ads there
but again in the different shape and
color so they are called
display ads because they've been
displayed on different websites and
different apps so why I'm going so fast
in explaining you different type of ads
because as I told you we have another
video created uh with the name of Google
ads for beginners 2023 you can just
check the link in the description and
you will able to get all this type of
ads and whatever the uh you know bidding
strategies to be used in basic in that
particular tutorial or that demo just as
to show you if you can see that ads by
Google so this is the display Adder
Banner right just quickly I have shown
you three types of the ads but our Focus
as I said today going to be on a very
specific ad which
is the most important ad from the Google
ads family okay so let's just begin guys
when I come to Google ads this is how
the Google ad structure looks like
we have a Google ads account created
again I repeat if you don't know how to
create it please find the link in the
description to create the Google ads
account once a Google ads account
created then you would have a dashboard
like this okay in this dashboard you can
see there are campaigns there are ad
groups there are ads there are videos
there are landing pages so a lot of
things can be confusing if you are just
coming to this account or to this
beautiful tool for the very first time
so to just keep it very simple or to
explain in uh in a very simpler way what
I did is I just drawn this structure for
you okay so the structure says that you
have a Google ads account imagine that I
am a simply learned Google ads manager
so I am running the ads for all simply
learn keywords like data analytics
course digital marketing course or any
machine learning course python course so
whenever somebody types this so there is
a ad which shows like from Simply learn
to probably we have to just assume
because currently I'm not able to see
any simple an ad here so data analytics
course India
and then probably we can see if there
are any
you can always change the keywords but
just to test time randomly changing the
words or I could have just written
simply learned specifically because I
want to go with simple learn only I have
researched a lot and I feel like this is
one of the best okay so probably there
is no ad though
still I would check
probably I have to just change the
chords
so I will go for the another course
which is by simply learn again and then
probably we can
expect any of the ads running
because this is not a very peak time so
we are probably you know saving some of
the cost not running the ads at this all
hour anyhow so we can assume that this
is the ad you know I am running for so
how we can create this ad how we can get
the best of clicks as I said it is not a
very best time to run the ad so this is
also kind of a change you know we can
bring into our ads by doing some
research so how all these things are
done we're going to be learning it okay
so when we come here to the dashboard
and then we see our dashboard looks like
this a bit complicated so we can be
confused we can be disheartened that I
have created the account by seeing uh
the first video but now I am all stuck
okay so probably I have to again wait so
the wait is over now we are here to
understand the whole structure okay so
let me just take a very simple example
suppose I uh I'm someone who's selling a
shoes okay because I have just said
simply learned probably let's just
convert it to any of the Google ads
account of a shoe seller probably I am
Nike okay and I am making the we had for
Nike shoes and I am selling two types of
the Nike shoes today probably formal or
Canvas OR probably I am selling the
casual or any sport shoes and what I did
I created the campaign named it search
ad
uh any month you know whatever the month
you have started with suppose November
so November 2022 that is the name which
I am giving name can be changed name is
something which is being put it up for
my reference so that after creating lot
of campaigns I'm not confused in which
campaign I have to check the results
okay so I'm running the server chart for
shoes for the month of February or
November or December 22 23 whatever and
then I open two ad groups into it why
I'm opening two ad groups under one
campaign because I'm selling two kind of
products under the shoes only I am
selling formal also
under the shoes only I am selling casual
also so what happens suppose I would
have just you know created one Heart
Group and would have inserted or
submitted all the keywords of formal and
Casual inside one hat group then if
somebody would have searched a term
called formal black shoes then this ad
group would have got confused that
should I show formal ad shoes or should
I show casual art shoes because what I
did I have just got all my keywords like
formal casual Cricket shopping jogging
party office you know all the mix of the
keywords from formal and Casual family
into the same ad group the moment any of
these six keywords being typed or been
searched on Google then this ad group
would have got triggered and then again
randomly it would have shown the ad of a
formal or ad of a casual because both of
the ads would have been under this okay
but after doing this bifurcation or
after doing this segmentation what would
happen all the formal keywords like
party shoes office shoes formal shoes
formal black shoes would go here
this ad group would trigger if any of
this keyword would search and
accordingly this ad which has everything
related to only formal shoes will be
shown and of course with that ad the
landing page is connected which would be
open you know when somebody clicks the
ad okay and vice versa if somebody would
have searched for a casual term like a
casual shoes sports shoes jogging shoes
running shoes then this ad group would
have triggered and then the casual shoes
ad with all the headline related to that
casual keywords would have been shown
and accordingly if somebody would have
clicked then the landing page of casual
shoes you know would have opened okay so
if this is clear actually you are very
much ready to uh dive into the Google
ads because many people takes a lot of
time to understand the structure because
uh you know maybe they are very much
confused at the art group level but I
have just tried My Level based by
bringing this example why I am creating
two different ad groups I why I'm not
just going with the same ad group you
know mixing all the keywords
second scenario could have been on a
second permutation could have been I
would have just you know probably
created two different campaigns all
together I would have named The Campaign
one with search ad formal shoes November
okay then only that only this part would
have belonged to the first campaign then
I would have created a different
campaign altogether and would have named
it campaign search ad
casual shoes November then this second
campaign or a second campaign can be
assumed here with you know with a green
color would have been drawn okay so this
is how on the structure it works like we
can always now create inside so let's
just see a few things uh before we
create the ad okay very important uh
requirement or rather I would say uh if
being the campaign manager of any any
any any company you name any startup you
name or any client you work with or
probably for yourself as well you have
to be very much sure how these terms
works like Okay so this terms when I
talk about is going to be a bit inclined
towards the search ad today only and
when I talk about the display ad in the
next video then I would you know take
you through about the terminologies and
all the kpis off display Banner or video
ads okay so now if I talk about a search
ad a very important
um term which we should be aware of is
the maximum bid price
okay because we all know when we're
talking about this ad which is called a
text ad then we are paying on every
click okay that's why this is also
called PPC ad this is also called PPC
marketing or you can understand in a
very simple words uh Advertiser which is
Emirates this in this particular ad only
has to pay when somebody like Sachin
this movement clicking this ad I click
this ad I reach to the landing page of
this particular University or this
college and a certain amount is deducted
from this particular ad account and and
that certain amount actually decides or
decided on the basis of the keyword
helped to show this ad okay so as an
Advertiser must have paid something to
Google ads for showing this ad for this
keyword okay so when I say a maximum bid
price it means it's a maximum bid price
of a keyword that's why now this would
be easier to understand by this example
suppose I want to run the ad on the term
called data analytics course 2022 what I
did I have opened the Google Keyword
Planner you know I did talked about this
in the previous session but I will take
you through again how you use a Keyword
Planner smartly so I have got this data
from the keywords planner that the
average price I have to pay for this
keyword to show my ad is 5 to 10 Rupees
so what I did I just played a bit of
maths and I have bidded something over
the minimum bit price okay this is the
minimum bit price is the maximum bit
price okay and this is what I've got
from the Keyword Planner so rather than
going for a very high price or the
maximum bit price to secure my position
I want to play safe and what I would do
I would just take a chance maybe 30 40
over the minimum bit range and then I
will see if the Impressions or clicks
are coming or not if this starts coming
it means that my ad is accepted and my
keyword is you know winning in the
auction and I'm able to get the clicks
but if it is not picking then certainly
I have to increase my bid price but
coming back to the terminology is what
we're talking here is once I have set it
up my maximum bit price of 7 rupees then
my ad would start showing suppose my ad
shows for 1000 times today and every
time when my ad been clicked you know
certain amount being deducted there is a
competition there are other advertisers
also you know who are running the ad and
after showing my ad for the whole day
Google in the dashboard just shown that
you have paid average CPC of 5 rupees
only so I bid it for 7 but by seeing
different uh you know factors like the
competition the demand and how many
times the ads got clicked what was the
position where my ad was shown I ended
up in paying five rupees for every Click
by the end of a day so the average CPC
sometimes you know people get confused
they have a CPC and the maximum bit
price is the same no so maximum bit
price is something which I uh you know
submit to Google that this is the
maximum I can pay for my add to show on
certain keyword for every click and I
have a CPC something which actually you
know I pay every day or you know in that
average of the duration your ad got
displayed or got clicks for every uh
click on that particular keyword okay or
the number of keywords if you have more
than one keyword submitted and suppose
I've got 100 clicks then you know it's a
simple match that my budget which I have
spent today is five rupees for one click
500 rupees 400 click so daily budget
would be 500 rupees and tomorrow if
company says I need 300 clicks then of
course my average CPC which I have from
the historical date of yesterday you
know I would just do my maths and I will
going to submit the daily budget of not
100 rather 300 today so that in 1500 I
can expect 300 clicks at the cost of 5
rupees per click okay so this is a very
simple of the example to just make you
explain how things works you know you
submit something then on the basis of a
lot of factors you know Google
calculates Google gives you clicks and
once you have the data then you know you
can just understand how this all is
working okay last thing before we dive
into the tool is Keyword Planner so I
just told you we have done in the last
class how this works like so we go into
tool and setting and then we go into
Keyword Planner I'll show you in the
account also the Google ads account just
after 30 seconds the screenshot's over
so your Keyword Planner opens and then
you discover the keyword suppose I am
selling data analytics course so I would
just put my search term data analytics
course and then I'll click the get
result and then accordingly it will show
me lot of options and this is the
pricing I was talking about it gives me
the low price and the high price so I
would take the 30 40 percent over the
low bid price or the average price
between these both and that would be my
maximum bit price and after checking all
the permutations Google would show my ad
or either it would not show my ad also
that there can be a chance so I have to
just wait for my impression and clicks
and the results by the end of a day and
I would you know I would know how much
the average CPC actually I'm paying for
each keyword okay so I'll show you all
those reports in a while uh that's it
right now let's just go and see few
things so the Keyword Planner will start
with suppose I start
um you know in researching all these
things my campaign is about data
analytics course
I'm making it for symptoms and I would
go and I would just try to you know
search into planning my Keyword Planner
and then I will write a term quickly
here you know whatever I want to show my
ad for
suppose data analytics course as I said
okay probably let's take digital
marketing because we would have more
uh results so it's
easy to understand with a lot of results
because I would be able to tell you how
to sort and filter them down uh digital
marketing course and you can just test
it with any of the keywords I'm just
doing a random check
so once we are here we have a lot of
keywords in addition to what we have
submitted so the keyword which I have
provided is this and the result shows
that it had over 100k uh you know
monthly searches and of course in the
range of 1 million in the in the in in
the month of 2021 to September 22 so
this is actually the average monthly
searches happened in between this period
and uh the advertise is actually paid as
low as 44 Rupees to as high 20 224
rupees okay that can easily be uh you
know converted to dollars uh half a
dollar or maybe more than half a dollar
UH 60 70 cents probably and this is like
going to be a three dollars cost okay so
what we can do is you can see now there
are a lot of keywords been given and we
can easily sort them down here on
certain you know bases like you know
suppose the monthly searches are high or
the bid is low and all that stuff but
this is quite you know difficult when we
have to sort down here in the Keyword
Planner so what I do is I'm just going
to talk about the same you know like hi
how I actually go when I am working for
my clients okay I have clients here a
lot of clients I don't want to show you
but yeah I have and um suppose I just go
and download this data from here
and then this would be you know
downloaded in the Excel format and we
can just save it anywhere suppose I just
bring it here and then now I would open
the keyword sheet
I would have a data in my Excel okay so
I need this this one so this is the most
important column because I have to
highlight uh which column is important
and what is not required right now so
whatever is required I'm just I'll be
keeping with me and what I feel like is
not very important as of now I'm just
not going to be taking them so now there
are
five column which I have kept with
myself like
4 where we talk about the results
and the keyword okay this is not
required this is not required so I'm
just going to be deleting or hiding them
okay so when we talk about our
competition index value so this actually
tells us that a particular keyword is
how much uh you know from the
competition point of view is difficult
to rank suppose I talk about two
keywords right now let me just take
um a one with a lower score suppose this
one and I would take the higher or the
highest one probably is this one okay so
now when I talk about a comparison you
know probably uh or or probably let's
say this this one because this has a
monthly searches which are equivalent uh
you know from the compression point of
view they are very different but the
search has been same so if I would stuck
to something of this sort that if I have
to finalize between these two so what I
would do you know that's something which
we are talking here you know if you have
a kind of combination where we have to
decide out of these two so both of the
keywords meaning very important if I
would just check from my naked eye a
quick Scan they look very promising they
look very great to me suppose and they
have a equivalent number of searches in
the last you know one year on the
average monthly basis but there is a
difference between the competition okay
now people can be confused what is this
competition so I would just make you
explain in a very simpler way Suppose
there are 100 companies so there are 100
you know ethic institutes or probably
physical institutes who teaches uh
digital marketing because we are doing
online marketing or you know digital
marketing course online so so let's keep
it online uh institutes like simply
learn and all okay so what they have
done is in the last one year they all
have used these keywords to run their
ads you know to show their advertisement
or their digital ad on a Google space
okay
when this data has been given so this is
telling me that out of those 100
advertisers or my 100 competitors
66 or a 66 percent advertisers have used
this ad
okay or have used this keyword to show
their ad okay and out of 100 33 percent
or if it is 100 then 33 advertisers have
used this keyword to show their ad okay
so it brings you know kind of a
comparison to US that probably these two
keywords are very much in demand you
know like equally from the searches
point of view because both have been
searched equally but whenever this has
been searched then there has been a
competition where 66 people or 66
advertisers or 66 percent advertisers
are fighting to show their ad okay and
when this keyword being searched as
equally then only 33 percent or 33
people or 33 advertisers are fighting to
show their ad on Google space okay when
I talk about 100 then it seems to be
okay where my AdWords look like you know
where my ad would show because if I just
go on a Google space you know that only
seven ads are shown when you know when
we go on a Google search engine one two
three and four and then the rest three
would be at the bottom if they are shown
at this moment or not I'm not very sure
so three would be here somewhere so
total seven adds placement on the first
page nobody goes beyond first we know
that 97 of the worldwide audience don't
don't go beyond the first pagination
okay so we have to be on our first page
so if I talk about from the first page
seven positions point of view it would
make more sense so let's imagine there
are only 10 advertisers of digital
marketing course so out of 10 if I take
out 66 66 percent then it means almost
like six to seven advertisers are
fighting or have bidded or probably are
trying to outrank each other to show
their ad on the top or on the first four
versions of Google but when I talk about
this then only three to four advertisers
are fighting or have bidded for this
keyword to show the ad on the first page
so this actually is a very important
data sometimes we just you know Miss it
because it has not been uh I think
explained anywhere else that what
exactly this value is we only go by the
low medium high which is the very first
column I delete nowadays you know I
don't you know go by this because they
both come under the medium but there is
a big difference you know seven out of
10 would have been bitted for and only
three to four would have been bidded for
this keyword so never go by the high
medium or low just go by the index value
okay that's a percentage of The
Advertiser who are actually trying to
fight for the same keyword to show their
ad on the top okay this is how we you
know shorten or we get the best keywords
we try to get the best search keyword
with the you know kind of a index value
between 50 to 60 less than that and then
we of course you know go for the bit
value or a bit price which is also on a
very lower side not a very high price
keyword we go with so this is the
criteria you know I actually follow and
that's something which you know you can
see I have also mentioned here you can
see that much uh you know we go for the
high search keyword and then we try to
get the low medium competition keywords
which of course less than 60 index value
and then I put a price you know kind of
a price of my price you know which is
like if the low bid price is 10 Rupees
then I just make it 13 by adding 30 to
it so if the pricing is 10 so I would
add 30 to it that makes my price 13 and
then I check you know uh if in the first
if the Impressions has come it means my
price actually been accepted but if any
of the keyword my price is not accepted
then I would again revise the price by
20 30 and then would wait on the
secondary report and that's how you know
I keep changing for the first two three
days and keep seeing the results and
once the you know every keyword gets
pick up and I get the you know it starts
getting the stable results then I uh
just as allow the campaign to work uh
you know on the algorithm and uh you
know I I see uh results actually moves
in the positive direction when you give
some time to campaigns to read and to
learn uh you know from the audience
Behavior okay so this is about the
keyword planning which we have just seen
now moving to again a very important
aspect because campaign making is
something which I've already given you
the you know Glimpse in the last class
so I would again give you today but
before that I really you know wanted
today to speak on all these technical
aspects you know which works at the back
end so that's why my focus is more on
this uh presentation parallely I would
keep showing you the uh you know uh the
uh Google ads other demo and everything
okay so now when we move to the next
part next part is very important from
the
um add algorithm point of view so what
happens or what used to happen uh when
when the quality score you know which
I'm just trying to speak now I was not
there uh what used to happen the one who
used to pay the highest bid price used
to get the first position and the second
one is to get the second position and
the third bidder used to get the third
position so I have just brought into
this table suppose a Advertiser has been
at 8 rupee B10 C 15 and D 20 and when
the quality score concept was not there
so they actually been given the very
direct position this one first this one
second this one third and this one
fourth but they have realized or Google
has realized that the one who is paying
the most is not having a very good
quality of the ad uh his uh landing page
or the website it's it's not working or
probably the pages which is which are
connected are not very relevant and the
keywords on which the ads been shown is
nowhere near uh you know when the
landing page is open so it it was like a
very negative impact on Google when the
reviews been checked and people or the
users who are clicking on those ads were
not happy so what Google did Google
brought us you know kind of um uh test
score or a check which is called quality
score for every keyword we bid okay and
this is only for the server chats that's
why I said all the keywords we made okay
I'll just show you the result on a
client side so when we submit our ad on
the basis of you know different keyword
we bid and the and the strategy we use
and the landing page we connected the
backend so what the system does is
system starts analyzing and starts
checking everything from top till you
know bottom from the start till the end
and I will just talk about the factors
and what impacts it brings is so the
quality score the score which has been
given out of 10 is then been given to
every Advertiser on the basis of the
keyword suppose every Advertiser here is
bidding on the same keyword you know
let's let's
um assume that they all are running the
ad for the digital marketing course so
what would happen they would check and
on the basis of the you know factors
they would give a score out of 10.
suppose the a Advertiser who bid it for
the least had the best of the quality
score because of the reasons we're just
going to talk about B got 8 out of 10 4
out of 10 and 2 out of ten so the one
who have bidded the most got for the
very least quality score probably the
reasons you know would be more clear
once we talk so how this allow we're
going to impact the whole position
system is that their Google rank not
Google position okay there is a Google
rank kind of uh kPa can be understood
before a matrix which is uh a product or
a multiplication of what you bid and how
much quality score you were able to get
so 8 into 9 being 72 10 into 8 brings 80
15 into 4 bring 60 and 22 is 40. okay so
the combination of a good pricing and a
good quality score got B bidder as a
first position okay and the one who got
the best quality score but still paying
very less from the average price in
globally is you know brought the Google
position or add position to Second and
then the one who was spring very high
but the quality score was below average
which is a Force 5 6 is average price
average score they've got into third
position and the one who was paying so
High probably would not get a position
because this is the maths from the match
point if we have got these numbers if
the quality score would have been below
five then the ad would not have got any
position rather because Google always
tries to you know show the ads which are
the best uh for the users you know
because Google always pays very
importance to the users behavior and
users um you know expectations so and
when I said that I think you were able
to understand more now how the factors
you know which which actually results in
these quality score is
um like relevant score like buy 11 score
means when you type a query or a person
would come here would type a query so he
doesn't know that this is called a
keyword we as additional marketers know
this is called a keyword for them it is
a normal query because they are about to
start a course where they would be
taught about all these things but right
now to they are not very aware you know
very much aware of these things so they
are putting a query when they put the
query they want to see the ad or add
extensions or a description relevant to
what they have searched and when they
see all these three things here with the
search you know what they made they
would definitely going to click more and
Google only earns when somebody clicks
so it means Google making Revenue only
when somebody is clicking so from that
perspective also Google always tries to
pay you know or rather give more score
and give a better position to the ads
where all the components of the ads are
perfect are relevant and the ones who
starts getting more clicks in the very
first hour or a first day okay so the
important factor which after the click
is the landing page so when somebody
opens this so it has to be very relevant
to this query and do whatever being
shown outside they cannot just show
anything here which is not relevant to
the ad which actually been shown outside
so all these uh you know factors in
combination gives the quality score very
important factor is CTR
which you must have understood when you
know we I I did you know explained in
the last session the basic one but if
you do not aware of it so CTR is called
click through rate okay and a click
through rate is a ratio of clicks to
impression
okay it is a ratio of clicks to
impression
I just a spell check okay so suppose
today
uh when we are saying ABCD so let's see
these are this is a or this is B and
this is C and they've got you know
equivalent quality score on the basis of
all what they have done okay their
landing page their ad their description
everything is very much common so Google
in the starting of the day you know when
the ad actually started to show for
everyone uh you know giving them a very
good quality score probably of five okay
and when this quality score of 5 been
given to them then the other factor
which actually adds on you know to that
algorithm is the CTR so CTR is I just
told you is the ratio between click to
impression so now they all have a same
quality score but this got 100 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions been
given today this got 50 clicks out of
the Thousand Impressions given today
this got by any mean probably 200 clicks
out of the Thousand Impressions given
today okay every time this this search
is happening here digital marketing
course so these
ads are very much visible equally so all
got thousand Impressions thousand
Impressions thousand Impressions but
this got 100 clicks they scored 50
clicks and they've got 200 Clicks in the
very first hour or maybe in the next two
hours okay so this CTR you know when we
are talking about 100 out of 1000 to 10
percent This Is 50 out of thousand it
means this is going to be five percent
and 20 uh sorry 200 out of 1000 means
twenty percent of the CTR so Google was
actually benefited or made the most of
the revenue and you know clicks have
come from here because it is almost like
a double or a four times of this so
because of the high CTR the quality
score of a force you know every every
Advertiser would improve but this one
would be improved from probably from
five to seven and this would you know
probably from five to five point five
and this is probably from five to six so
because of that quality score has
improved and uh you know because of the
high CTR this ad has got so this
position will be changed and this would
you know we probably would get the first
page on the second position and and at
the end of a day this ad has to pay or
Advertiser has to pay lesser because
it's quality score increase we have just
seen it is you know almost like the uh
you know inversely proportional the ones
who are actually paying or the ones who
are having the best of the quality score
are paying the least one has to pay the
least okay so this is all basically you
know can be checked once your ad starts
running so I will just open the clients
account uh where you can just see this
with
you know better
understanding you would able to get out
of this
hopefully I am able to show you from
okay I'll just see because I have
multiple
advertisers you know
but I cannot just show for all so let me
just check if I can show you how many of
the older one
just wait it is actually asking you some
verification
it's taking too much time
yeah it's just done now
so once this is done
so I'll just take you to one of the
accounts where
my main focus will just show you how the
quality score report look like and then
you know you know you will get a fair
idea about all the factors you have to
be focusing to bring your quality score
high or to take your qualities for high
okay
so I'm just going to open the search ads
because we're talking about a search ad
here only and suppose if I just go into
this
Campaign which is of course you know not
running right now but I just want to
show you how you check the report and
all suppose this is the campaign you
have run for and you got 75 clicks at uh
you know
um app with CPC price of 40 peso and you
have just given this much pricing and I
have bided for many keywords but I want
to see which keyword had got the best of
the quality score and how the qualities
have been given and all okay so once you
reach to the keyword report here you
know at this level then you see
um uh you know the kpis or metrics here
which gives the quality score out of 10.
okay you can see here very well and
every keyword being given another you
know if there are 10 keywords I don't
know how many keywords we build it for
we've bidded 50 keywords okay and you
know you can see all the keywords here
and every keyword been given the quality
score out of 10 okay because their CTR
which was the last part which I've
explained you the ratio between the
impression two clicks got the above
average so they give below average
average above average so above average
is best actually for any of the factors
so the CTR is above average the landing
page is above average and their ad is
above average means all are perfect then
they got the 10. the moment anything
goes below average or probably to the
average suppose you can see this is
above average for them this is above
average for them but they're landing
page experience from this keyword point
of view is only average their quality
score has come to eight okay if you go
further down uh let's see anything where
two of them yeah so here the kids ride
on is a keyword where CTR is also not as
high or as great you know to as compared
to the other keywords which we have seen
and also the landing page is not as
relevant to the keyword so there are two
factors like CT and landing page has
come to average as compared to the
Android 11s which is above average so
their whole quality score got impacted
which actually came down from 10 to 8
and then 7 for this particular keyword
and last not PC if I just take you to
somewhere where
something is below average has come now
one is above average one is okay they
are getting clicks but probably the ad
is still not very much relevant to the
keyword okay so they are below average
above average has brought the quality
score to 6 out of 10 which certainly
would have you know impacted on the cost
and also to the position okay so this is
something which you would see
when you come here also you can check
one more thing here suppose you have
bidded for your keyword and your bid
price where you are paying for is
maximum bit price let me just see where
that column is
so otherwise I would just add that
column so that you can learn that part
as well
okay
[Music]
let's wait okay so this is basically
CPC prize is being given in the average
cost 2.50 is the cost for every click
and we got 249 clicks so got 623 you can
just check the maths it's always good to
cross check so 249 clicks multiplied by
the CPC price which is 2.50 rupee would
give you 6 22.5 which is the cost you
know for the keywords uh you know we
beat it for and the total clicks we have
paid okay and the
maximum beta price suppose you know you
have got uh the maximum bit price of uh
one rupee and you paid 17 PESA 1.66 and
all and then what happens you wanna
secure your position suppose the very
first page bid you're seeing that you're
getting the position but you're not
getting the first page then here because
this campaign is not running so I'm just
giving you the hypothetical example so
whatever the pricing you would have
given for the particular keyword suppose
we talk about these three keywords right
now a particular one keyword uh I
suppose so this is something which I'm
you know trying to show on a one rupee
cost but to show on the first page it is
saying that you have to pay 1.5 okay to
show on the first four positions here
one two three four it is saying that
probably you have to pay 2.5 and to get
the absolute first position which is
going to be the topmost it would tell
you that you have to probably pay 5
rupees you know you bring one it is
asking 1.5 the first four it can be paid
for 2.53 or this has to be five so you
can always go and change your you know
bid price for the particular keyword
okay so there are ways to do it suppose
if I'll just go here and I just go to
the edit I can change my maximum CPC bit
price for this particular bid or a
keyword like 25 rupee okay because I'm
not changing for all the keywords so I
have selected that particular keyword
and I have made the change to this
particular keyword to five rupee so if
you know the average price was one and I
was not getting the keyword uh from this
keyword the position secured on the
first page or the first absolute
position and I want because this is the
most important keyword for me then I
would just come here and would check the
pricing okay this is five rupees you
have to pay for the top position so I
will just go here edit and would change
the bid price or a maximum CPC bit price
of this particular keyword you can do
for all you know you have to just of
course you know select all of course but
if you would do for all then it it can
really impact your whole budget okay so
try to go for the keywords where you
really feel like it is required and
always go by the quality score it has
you know it has a very good quality
score so I should be paying or I should
be ready in paying uh the maximum price
which actually Google is asking me to
pay to secure my first absolute position
and certainly that would increase the
chances of clicks and certainly if
clicks are there so convergence can be
expected too okay so this is all from
what I've just taught you as of now
I would just move to the campaign making
though we have done as I told you last
time but I will try to make it again so
that we can quickly see how the Google
ad search ads or the search Google had
created okay so if I just go to the
campaign uh My Demo
account so if you just go to the Google
ads account the dashboard and then I
would come to the campaigns
I will just click Plus
new campaign
and whatever the you know
objective is you can always go for
website traffic or without a guidance
because this would have all the settings
inside the same more important part is
what we select next so we select search
campaign because we are making the ad
for the search Network you can always
test for website traffic that would not
make much difference and click continue
I will talk about the conversions and
remarketing in a separate session
altogether so we are not doing the
conversion and remarketing today we are
making a normal search ad with all the
strategies we have just understood and
with uh adding the extensions to the add
as well today okay website visit and
suppose my website is just open safety
learns
landing page
so that I can make the ad for simply
additional marketing as a demo ad of
course not a
mean add so copying and just putting in
here I have to just put a you know
website domain that's it I don't have to
bring the whole landing page here and
then I can just name it probably
November
search and
and then I would just go and continue
start new
and then I'll just select my bidding
strategy which is going to be clicks
and of course from my Excel I would
learn that okay my bid price which I am
going to be paying uh you know is
certainly in the range of something like
probably 50 60 and I have just told you
that I bring my price kind of a thing
into this like I always bring like this
and then
let me just delete all the other columns
which are not required
so this is the sheet which I did explain
to earlier with the index value and all
so my price what is my price like so I
always pay 30 40 extra to the low bit
price so I can you know just get the
formula here like
this
Plus
this 30 percent
okay so that is just going to make it 57
so you can just understand 44 plus 13
going to bring 57 and I can just drag it
and now I've got the average suppose
these are the you know keywords which I
have finalized just assuming so these
are the keywords which I have finalized
probably because of x y z factors such
as an index value and all that and I see
that my pricing is varying from 35 to 89
so maximum being 89 so what I would do
keeping that in my head I was going to
give the limit to my bid price and I
don't want to pay anything extra or more
than 90. okay so this is something which
you can do on this particular level
and then you move ahead and you remove
this because you just want to keep your
ad on the Google search
and then you go down you select your
countries you select your location if
you want to show the ad in all the
locations then you certainly can just go
and keep the very first option open
which is all countries and territories
if you want to just show your ad
um
in a particular country like you know
right now if I just go India so the
whole India would see your ad and if you
want to go for a manual locations like
suppose I want to select any of these
states or cities then what I would do I
would just probably take daily so Delhi
would be targeted like this okay or
probably I just want to Target the state
of Texas here so I just would go and
Target the whole state or if I want to
Target any of the provinces of Canada so
I would just go and take the uh
provinces of Ontario Canada and I will
just Target the whole Province and now
if I also want to go for any of the PIN
codes suppose I want to Target to a
certain pin code then I can just go and
Target the PIN codes like this so it is
up to us that we want to go worldwide or
if you want to go for a country specific
if you want to go for us State specific
or if you want to go as a province or a
pin code specific okay otherwise if you
suppose
um a restaurant or if you are a you know
somebody who only delivers into certain
radius then you can just leave all these
options and you can go and advance
search
and then you can go to radius and you
can just bring this whatever you
understand better in India we understand
kilometers better maybe the person us
would understand miles better so we just
go and take that two kilometer radius
and probably I am the cake shop in Delhi
so I will just go into search my
location this is my location and now
we're just going to Target people around
two kilometer because I don't deliver
outside two kilometers so it's all up to
us how we're gonna go uh this is called
radius targeting or geofencing when we
go to the locations we can also learn
one thing suppose I want to show the ad
to the
um whole country India app targeted at
the same time I am not delivering in um
uh in in in Mumbai okay or probably in
Karnataka you know Bengaluru where the
city is okay or probably I'm not
delivering in any of the uh northern
states like haryana Himachal Punjab so
what I would do I would just take Punjab
suppose for example and I'm just going
to exclude that okay so what would
happen now my ad would show in all these
states and all the cities of India but
just not in Punjab okay so I can save it
that's how you go about the location
language is you know in which language
the users probably uses the search
engine and all so you can keep it all
languages that's the best and
audience we don't cater here much
because we are doing the search ad which
actually shows the ad on the basis of
keywords and location only so in the
display ad we're going to talk about
this uh one and that would be the next
video I would create so we're going to
learn a lot of things from the audience
segment in the next display ad and then
the more settings comes where you talk
about the ad rotation so add rotation is
already default been selected as the
perform best ad uh if because the
nowadays the ad actually been created uh
responsive and dynamic so when we'll
reach to the ad level I'll show you uh
the headline changes for every user the
description sometimes changes for the
user what I mean is if Sachin is
selecting or you know writing this
keyword so probably this headline is
shown to me and after one hour if I'll
come again and put search the same term
so the headline from the same Advertiser
could be different or the description
could be different so that's how these
anime cards works like okay so once you
are done with this okay the start end
date is important and you know the
basics from the previous chapter so I'm
just going a bit faster in here so you
would select the date and
then if you want to schedule this
campaign for a certain period like
suppose you don't want to run on the
weekends so you can just select Monday
to Fridays and you know our timing
whichever suits you suppose just like a
very common time of 8 AM to uh you know
the late nights like 23 45 and you don't
want to run the weekends if you want uh
Saturday Sunday to be you know 24 hours
then you don't have to put any timing so
that goes like 24 hours for Saturday
Sundays and then you click next and you
reach to the next level
where it will just going to ask you for
certain things like keywords you want to
submit and the ad you want to run for
and the ad copy you know you have to
create okay so once you come here it is
the you know work you have done so you
can just copy paste them and you know
bring in there and otherwise these all
keywords are the ones which Google has
suggested you from you know the page
which you have submitted okay so the
landing page is this so I'll try to
change the landing page first so that I
can get more appropriate keywords and
then it would mean to search again on a
scan again for us update keyword
suggestions of course we can always
click on and now the keywords would be
more digital marketing oriented because
this landing page will be scanned by
Google and this would show a certain
results which would of course going to
be digital marketing oriented but why we
don't just uh you know use them because
we don't know uh what is the pricing of
these keywords is what is the
competition of this keywords is how much
the monthly search has been so we go by
our own maths we we calculate we do all
this free homework on the Keyword
Planner sheet just like we did today and
then we bring them here by deleting all
what they have actually submitted or
suggested us okay and once this is done
then we ensure that our keyword uh uh
you know in the headlines and everything
been used how that copy is created I'll
just show uh you some you know strategic
part of it ensure that your landing page
is correct and it is opening there you
know otherwise your ad would not be
approved secondly always give a display
path display path is something which is
added after the ad or the landing page
link suppose I'm selling online
foreign
digital marketing so I would just going
to write whatever I want to show
probably I'll just keep it here
okay
okay so that works okay so now it has
computational marketing and then the
part comes where you know you have to be
foreign
once the ad is created so headlines and
all so the headline is something which
shows
you know you know the basics where I'll
be fast again
under the landing page link this blue
which actually uh you know brings the
most of the engagement or which actually
appeals the user to click it is
something in blue which is you know
going to be the headline so we have to
be focusing very much on bringing the
best of the headlines here so that we
can get the best of the clicks because
you know once the click increases the
CTR increases CTR increases the quality
Square would increase quality Square
would increase your costing would come
down and your position would rise so you
have to ensure that your headlines your
clicks everything is in you know in a
line whatever we have learned so your
headlines right now has been given these
of course they are not very relevant so
we're going to just bring the headlines
which we feel like are more relevant to
the ad we are showing okay and
I'm just going to get the headlines as a
suggestion being given okay and
we can have more ideas from here by
clicking this so they are not giving any
so we can always have from the keywords
which we have submitted so probably
digital marketing course online
try to get your best keywords here
this is okay
this is nice this can be changed
digital
marketing course
online is not taking
so this Marketing Online probably I'll
just take because course I already
submitted and then I can take few more
like social media marketing I just seen
whatever the length it would accept
I'll take otherwise I'll delete the rest
this is the one and I should ensure that
I have at least 10 headlines or 12
headlines so six been given and headline
section actually you know been given egg
a half blue and then I would see
headlines which are unique so unique you
should have a uh you know online
availability benefits and the offers and
all or call to action so enroll
register
today
for free
demo
then we will talk about
you can see the moment I've added the
headline this the strength has changed
100 plus
tools for free
job
assistant
program
okay so I'm just adding a few random
things I'm just not paying much
attention but yeah of course we would
have seen these headlines in any of the
at 10 companies ads uh include some
popular QRS popular keywords could be
your brand name as well so simply
learn
courses
online
of hopefully the spelling is fine and
um
we can batch for
professionals
oh
um
[Music]
just a batch of professionals
and that's it you know because I already
added a lot of keywords a lot of red
lines probably Revenge so I would just
not work on the headlines anymore uh
I'll see you know if deception doesn't
takes it high then I'll just add one
more but right now the description is
also not giving me the full uh take like
in the headline unique and the headlines
been given so I'll just try to bring the
description so simply an online to do
online that's great that's great so just
try to get something from Google itself
let's see what they have given so I'll
just going to bring this one
okay so that it is being taken from the
landing page itself so that would make a
difference to
uh the quality score simple digital
marketing courses focus on so we're just
going to put
our courses focus on skills
co22
focus on
else like Su C another tags
so we're doing this one here so that it
has been picked up so now you can see
this has also been picked up and the
last thing I would do is now going to
bring some headline uh again you know
I'll just check probably
uh digital marketing
notification I'm not sure if this
headline I have submitted earlier or not
but I'm just going to test it out okay
so
you should
thank you
training
so now it has you know come down to good
and uh that's the best you know right
now we can do of course so you can take
it further but yeah that doesn't
um matter if you are just stuffing it to
get this one completed you have to just
ensure that all the keywords all of the
headlines are relevant just do not
overdo 10 to 12 are okay okay once this
is done your ad is created you can just
click done and you can click next
and then your budget so we just
discussed about the budget when I was
explaining we'll just take you back so
because you know that your average CPC
price would be around 80 you know
whatever the pricing you have just got
from here if you know the sheet and I
was explaining you so the the bit price
which you have submitted for you know
when I told you is like something which
is in this range uh like 80 90 whatever
it is so you know that bit price would
come down to 90 and you need
um at least 100 clicks today so 90 into
102p your 9000 daily budget so because
you know that you know you would end up
in paying maximum 90 rupees per click
because that's the maximum bit price you
have submitted if that comes down to 70
80 60 then of course your clicks would
increase but right now though being very
uh you know hypothetic hypothetically
thinking that okay I would pay 90 rupees
per click at Max because that is what I
submitted so to get 100 clicks I have to
pay 90 into 100 which would be 9 000
your you know delivers it has to be so
we would have come here and you were
just going to change it set a custom
budget and you were going to bring down
9000 Rupees here okay so on that yeah I
have a CPC whatever it would be you
would get the number of clicks if you
have a CPC goes down from 90 to 45 then
of course you are not going to get only
100 you'd rather get double amount which
is going to be 200 okay once that is
done then you just click next and your
budget goes you know your campaign goes
for a review
and then you can add the extensions from
outside okay so they're just giving you
some of the uh you know kind of uh
suggestions so let's see uh there is one
issue in the ad
let me just check that first
let me just see
you can always fix it
with that foot again you're not going to
give you the option of um publishing you
know till you fix it but it is not
clickable or not no
uh what is the problem
I'll just go away from here you know
sometimes those links doesn't work so
let's see what is the issue
foreign
[Music]
okay so because just to do that the
better limit part I have not given the
space so that is something which is not
acceptable by them
I just want to put like skills like this
and
now so these all small things you know
they do
take care of so here only because we
have come down so why not you know just
to see the extension here itself because
that would I'm going to save our efforts
by going from outside so when you see
the ad you see some extensions here like
you know when you have created the ad
right now so you have created only till
this limit okay this is the elements you
have put it up right now the landing
page the headline the description but in
this ad by emirators you can see more
links like applied to IMS learn how
industry so one is landing page and
three different uh Pages or a sub page
has also been shown in this same ad how
they are done so they are done through
the extension called site link okay so
you can see here if you go down after
the headline there's an option to have
the site links here okay so you can just
click Plus
here itself you know I'm not submitting
the ad because I wanted just to show you
from here itself and then you can go
down because in your case these would
not be given because mine are already
created yours or not so you would go
down and you would create the new South
new site link from here and you can just
give a name suppose download
brochure
and then you can give a URL of that
download brochure page right now I'm
using this URL and I'm just going to be
adding my own made page
like this like this has to be the
landing page which is workable for the
downloading brochure of course so this
would be added and then I can just go
and probably add
um
testy nails
and reviews
okay so somebody wants to read the uh
you know testimons and reviews of when
when they see the ad so you can see that
on the desktop how that would look like
so they would have an ad and then they
would have these four links involved
which you have just seen in the Google
when I shown you so final URL of reviews
can be given which would directly take
them to the page where the reviews being
given and site 2 could be anything you
know which can just see
um industry ready modules or the fee
structure you know the fee structure is
something which people always wants to
just know
from the uh very first glimpse of the
art itself so I can just maybe
take them to the page where fee is
actually been you know talked about and
the last could be uh maybe tools
provided
the tools and
certificates
you would get so that can also be one of
the links which people would very much
interested in you know clicking and
checking okay so you would see the the
ad in certain shape you would have a
normal headline uh the description which
you have put it up and then four links
where people can directly reach okay and
then you know this had to be saved here
and you can always see the preview which
I've already shown you but yeah this is
how that would look like so you add
your ad and your four
extra links which actually been added
okay so this is one which you can apply
now
and now your ad has the extensions in
addition to that you might have seen
somewhere that you know your ad has the
number as well sometimes you see the
number being given here because right
now it is not showing any of the ads
with the number but the you know uh
generally have when advertisers have
nowadays the numbers in addition to the
headline and everything okay so you can
add that as well by just going up and
you can see there is an option of calls
okay okay let me you can add from here
uh certainly I can show you but you know
you can just go down and add the number
by clicking your
country and you know giving your number
here it will just be cross checked by
some verification and all so that is
done you can save it so you can see what
actually I was showing you you know I
would just show you
um from outside also that if by any of
the uh you know
um that is done that we have corrected
so you don't have to be you know
uh worried about so if I just click done
so that should not be there if it is
still there I have to check now which
spacing it is actually talking about
um actually I have an acceptable spacing
contains comma and I think I have just
corrected it but it is not taking maybe
I have to just
um
delete the whole description properly
that would something which
and I would say about time
okay so we're not adding the description
though
just click done so this is actually you
know kind of a bug because that is
something which has been deleted rather
in front of you so this is not um
taking but I would just click next and
probably this would now be not the error
in which we would see
so you go for a review so what I was
saying I did shown you from outside the
you know the the campaign was created
from the ad itself how the site link is
connected and how the uh call been added
for now the publish campaign you can see
because that ad error actually been
rectified so if by mistake you know you
just forgotten that you have to add the
call number or extension you know which
we just started so but you don't have to
be worried because once you back to the
dashboard you know where you would see
all your campaigns certainly you would
see your this campaign as well in which
you had just created then you can just
go inside the
um add group and then
you can see there is ADD and assets
let me just click that
so there is an ad which you just created
and there is an assets
you know where you could see the
extensions and all like you know you
just have added today now we just
started this site link and this number
so if I want to add again or if I would
have forgotten then what I can do I can
just go and take from here suppose if
that call extension was not added there
you know when I just added you would
come here in the assets you would click
that plus button
and then you would just go to the call
and you would see the same kind of a
preview which you have seen inside the
ad when we were creating okay nothing
different it's just like the you know
where you do it you know either you do
when the ad was created or otherwise you
can just go uh let the campaign be
created published and you can come from
outside you can click the add an assets
you can go to plus and you can create
any of these extensions I will talk
about more in the coming you know
tutorials and demos uh and the sessions
but today you know we'll wind up here I
just uh you know wanted to give you the
thorough learning on the Google search
ad with the extensions and also the main
uh agenda for today was to make you
understand how these you know terms
works like and how the keywords can be
researched how you can bring your own
pricing to the keywords how can you save
the cost and of course to understand how
the quality score works like you can
have a lot of videos on a YouTube where
you can find the quality score of Google
ads working though I try to you know
bring everything under this session but
still if you want to go for a deep
learning you can always search more and
research more
so thank you from my side please leave
your comments with your feedbacks if you
have any questions you can always leave
in the comments and if you are watching
the very first video on our Channel I
request you to if you have not
subscribed it please subscribe it and do
not forget to press the Bell icon so
that you're not uh you know leaving any
of the important notifications okay so
we have a lot of content uh just not on
digital marketing on every topic you
know you would name it and you would
find it it's it's a great platform to
learn and to you know improve your
skills uh just just be a part of this
community and as I said we always try to
improve and you know your comments
always motivates us so leave your
valuable comments and I will see you in
the next tutorial very soon that would
be completely on Google ads Display
Network and where I would talk about the
audiences and you know a lot of
targeting methods which are differ from
the search ad and and later I would you
know talk about the advanced
you know session of remarketing and
conversion and all so a lot of things
are coming if you have not subscribed
please subscribe so you don't miss
anything thank you so much uh this had
Sachin cycle again signing off from
Simply learn have a great day ahead God
bless take care of yourself and your
families bye
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learning YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here